[Music]
this
is star talk sports edition and this is
going to be cosmic queries
grab bag but a particular kind of grab
bag because we're going to think about
sports not only on earth but
off world and of course i've got with me
my co-host
chuck neistat hey neil what's happening
oh right our professional stand-up
comedian who's actually in pretty good
physical shape even though you never
really did any sports in your life is
that correct
i mean i i have played sports in my life
i just don't talk about the disaster
that it was
okay that's all there it is okay that's
honest
and i've got gary o'reilly former soccer
pro from the uk
gary my co-host all right dudes well
so this kind of subject is fun because
it involves sort of the
physics of sports as played in different
sort of gravitational atmospheric
environments
and while i can take you some of the way
there when you
really want to do it right we got to go
for our
geek in chief and there's only one
person with that title
in this sector of the universe perhaps
the entire universe perhaps
the multiverse itself charles lew
charles welcome
back to star i don't i'm not worthy oh
no
it's such a pleasure to be back thank
you thank you man you know i we have to
bring you back with
enough frequency so that i don't get big
headed about my
own geek expertise right because after a
while i said yeah i got this
i got this and then you put you in the
same room with me
and it's like no i don't got this
we're in this we are all in this
together neil you have your expertise
i have mine no the continuum it's all
good you you come in from beyond the
horizon of the continuum that i occupy
let me just say it that way how's that i
i do not know if i agree but thank you
for your time
it's always a pleasure to be here and
talking about science and
sports and literally everything else
yeah well every everything and
charles is a friend and colleague and
he's a
professor of physics and astronomy at uh
city university of new york on staten
island
and some people don't know that he was
with me
20 years ago when we were building and
finishing
the new hayden planetarium in rose
center so yeah i was six
at that time
[Laughter]
i was i was being squeezed into the
corners to make sure that children
couldn't get stuck
charles little the young sheldon of the
hayden
[Laughter]
so we got you charles here and so but
just why could you just
uh you know we've got questions from
patreon which has been our our sole
source
if you want to get questions on cosmic
queries you can join patreon for a very
low
entry level i mean we want you to you
know go a little higher but entry level
gets you
get you at least this far on it and so
charles do you have just an overarching
thoughts about
sports on earth versus what might be
necessary
on other planets if we were a
multi-planet species for example oh yeah
the basic point is that all
human motion is fundamentally pushing
against
gravity everything we do whether we're
walking or we're standing or we're
jumping or anything like that trying to
hit a baseball
trying to keep it off the ground
everything is based on gravity
when it comes right back down to it so
in the end
if you're an environment where there is
no gravity or microgravity
then your own personal forces take over
those activities
suddenly your physiology matters way
more suddenly the
environment in which you are playing the
size the shape the speed all the
different things matter
it's going to change sports
fundamentally no matter where we go in
the universe as long as it's not
9.8 meters per second squared
acceleration wow
so finally we can play quidditch in
outer species
except that you know if you get hit by a
bludger
uh you don't fall right where are you
gonna go right
oh that's right because yeah i forgot
about that because they
even though they're flying around
they're still
magically if they fall off they fall to
the ground and that they're
that hurt they're still there still in
play
the play field all right however if you
were playing
jetpack quidditch
and your broom has its own propulsion
so um as in rockets right
when you do get hit you'll be knocked
off course you have to correct in order
to come back so
but you won't but you won't fall to the
ground that's right there you go
as a spectator i haven't come to see you
do quite nicely i've come to see you go
splat gary did you just say what is the
fun
of quidditch in outer space no
yes without without the floor to land to
smash
into without falling yeah wait wait wait
so charles
the the so maybe
we're thinking we're too narrow in our
thinking
maybe the sports that we have honed on
earth
were conceived in a sort of a 1g
environment
maybe if we go to the moon at at
one-sixth gravity or
or mars at 40 percent 38
gravity maybe we should say what sports
would can we invent sports that would be
best served by those gravitational
fields
and not try to port something from earth
to these other locations
i agree with you completely whole new
kinds of sports
and i thought i have an argument just
agreeing with me charles you just agree
i completely agree with you
well on mars i know it will be mutant
badminton
where your little mutant like cuado
is the only one actually allowed to hold
the
racket so so the little mutant growing
out of your chest
i got you there it is i thought the
mutant comes out and does a slow soft
shoe
well yeah but he'd have to use your feet
that's no problem
oh no not again yeah so so that's a good
way to think about it now so who's got
the questions chuck you do you have the
questions from patreon
both gary and i have you both
yeah okay so who goes first i'll jump in
i'll jump in
okay one of our patreon patrons uh
what elements or considerations would be
important for an
outer space sport so we're going to
drill a bit deeper into what we've just
discussed
he says i'm guessing it's a he william i
would love to see an ender's game style
arena but what would really be
entertaining to watch
people compete at in space so we've got
again the entertainment i need someone
to hit the floor i need entertaining so
when he says
he means he implies zero g i think when
he's saying in space right
i think it's it's that without the net
to save you or no net to not save you
where is that where is the risk factor
that we all are going to watch someone
defy the risk because due to their
expertise all right
um the for those people who aren't
familiar with ender's game that was a
novel written by orson scott
card a number of decades ago where to
fight an
alien menace a number of children were
put into a place called the battle
school
and they were out in space and trying to
figure out all kinds of new strategies
and methods that the adults put them
in and it was a little creepy of a book
actually
um but nevertheless
chuck i knew that i knew everything you
just said i knew that
so
neil your nose has grown by about six
inches no
of course you do but but the it was very
interesting orson scott car did a good
job trying to imagine
what fighting and combat would be like
in zero g in a number of those cases was
later made into a movie with various cgi
effects and things like that
i don't know that they did as well as as
we would have liked them to but
you know what would be fun a boxing
match if i hit you
we both you foil from that contact
that's right
so so what we're probably going to be
talking about my guess is that
you're you're going to be thinking much
more about uh
evade and capture type games as opposed
to
retrieving and object type games so
football soccer baseball and those kinds
of things you hit a ball it's going to
go everywhere
it's going to you know you just have to
go get it and then there's no air
messing with it the spin will be hard to
work with
um rather it'll be like can you grab
that person that's going from point a to
point b
uh before the person gets there uh
there's probably going to be issues of
musculature uh are you going to bounce
off the corner yeah how big is the space
going to be
can you change your position and then
the equipment will matter so much too
just as chuck was saying earlier about
jet packs right
uh if you can't if as soon as you launch
yourself up
in the same way that a basketball player
leaving the floor knows
where uh you're coming down
you're gonna have to launch yourself and
know where you're gonna be headed
unless you put some sort of energy or
force uh behind where you're working or
what you're doing
so it's going to be much more physics
based well it's not only that
charles i mean on earth we can move
forward
or in any direction we choose because
this friction between us and some other
surface
that enables that but um in space
any time you want to change direction
you have to give up some mass
in order to do that right you can't just
choose to change direction
something has to has to has to come out
of you so that you
recoil in the opposite way with your
momentum
and that's the only way you can change
direction oh i thought you
had to pray in order to change direction
you just give up some bad
gymnastics yeah i mean what's the point
if i do a triple somersault
i could do 30 somersaults and i'll just
keep going
gymnastics will no longer exist in zero
gravity sorry
i'm not a gymnastics hater i'm just
saying well here's what you would do
then right
you create a circumstance where you
have to leave one surface maybe you're
pushed off of one surface
and before you reach the other surface
then you have to do all your
things the other thing that you could do
though is
you could have magnetized gravity boots
so
from surface to surface you know the
the magnetic is turned off on one you
push off and then as you go
then it's turned on the other and it's
that's when it pulls you and sticks so
right so like space space pradas
yeah well wait so if if it's a magnetic
stick then you always stick the landing
because you will connect to the magnet
if it's electro magnets that they just
turn on yeah
but it could be cool too for wrestling
so neil think of it like this well i'm
asking i shouldn't say think of it this
way because i've never wrestled anybody
except my own demons
[Music]
stand strong
but okay let's say you're wrestling
right
so you're on the platform and
you have certain points of your body
that have magnetized
uh like uh like knee pads elbow pads
and your shoes okay so while you're
wrestling these are turned on
okay the the floor is magnetized you
guys are actually wrestling
but at any point they can
turn it off maybe it's on a cycle so
it'll be so it'll be very
uh fair to everybody it's going to be a
cycle or it's regularly
random you're going to do it random or
random right
so now how does that change you as a
wrestler
because is it left is it leverage
everything
right and at some points you're going to
be floating and then what move do you
have to think of
while you're floating so that when the
cycle
starts again you're in a better position
to
dominate your opponent so magnetic
strategies or what that is all about
very cool i like that i like that
damn all right well this whole segment
is just about sports and space so let's
keep going who's got the next question
all right
uh i'll guess i'll bring up the next one
this is from fitzfritz
menzel hey neil if there were a zero
gravity sport that involved
athletes launching or jumping from one
wall of a huge arena to the other
what speed could they reach
what would happen when they hit the
other wall
[Laughter]
so charles what's tell me about the
symmetries of jumping and landing
in that let's do the quick calculation
okay d equals one half eight t
squared the typical athlete can probably
jump about what
two two meters in the air five six feet
if they're really really accomplished
uh so you get your center of mass six
feet in the air that's that's pretty
good
right yeah but but they're working
against gravity if we're just going to
put yourself into motion
that's not the right calculation i don't
know what i'm trying to do is to figure
out how much
force and acceleration a typical athlete
can create by pushing off
if we're talking about pushing off on
okay so then you've got a direct
measurement okay
yeah direct measurement so so uh two
equals one half
gt squared so that's five two fifths
point four what's the square root of
point four
so point four is point yeah it's about
0.6 right yeah a little bit between 0.6
and 0.7
so you're going for 0.6 seconds
deceleration at 10 meters per second
that means you're you're able to launch
yourself
at approximately six tenths of
of gravity right six tenths of a meter
per second something like that
six meters per second all right so you
can go so you're going six meters per
second and let's say you weigh about 100
kilograms 220 pounds something like that
so that's um okay but the thing is if i
can jump
if i can if i can propel myself at that
speed
i will arrive at the far wall at that
very same speed
that's right so i'm trying to figure out
how much damage you would do to your
face
the answer is well i mean we can do the
math specifically but let's let's just
do it intuitively
if i jump at full speed into a wall
right or if i say i jump as hard as i
can and i'm in a room that's only
uh three inches higher than my head
think about the the
impact that i would feel on my head when
i hit it
right especially if you're if you're
face up when that happens yeah basically
that's the end of your face that's right
so it's a lot
i mean you can really cause yourself
serious damage no question about it
right so what you'd have to do is while
you were floating from one surface that
you just jumped from
to the other you'd have to somehow turn
around right so that you landed on your
feet
and then you use your entire
musculoskeletal system to absorb absorb
the land right as a shock absorber
exactly so basically
our sports in zero g will be performed
by cats
highly padded humans right
it's so funny all right give me another
one and what else you got
all right um okay matthew ritter i've
heard that due to titan's thick
atmosphere and low gravity that powered
flight
would be possible we'd also
be super man
charles i had not heard of that is it is
that what's the thickness of titan's
atmosphere do you remember
uh it's a little bit more than earth's
atmosphere actually but
but if it's only a little bit more uh
yeah one point something or two point
something earth okay
so it's not like venus where it's a
hundred times atmosphere it's it's of
order earth's atmosphere okay so where
do you gain most going to
holding aside the fact that you'll get
vaporized on venus
ignoring that complication is the
atmosphere
thick enough for you to gain lift just
by your own
uh strength or do you have to go to the
lower gra because venus has earth
gravity what do you have to go to the
lower gravity of titan
and take advantage of that fact against
the slightly higher
uh density atmosphere um i would go
with i would go to titan uh
the the advan because you realize that
venus's atmosphere is so thick that it's
like being
down half a mile in earth's oceans
to be at the surface of venus right so
even our
best nuclear submarines have a hard time
surviving at that level
so even if you can build an airplane you
could be crushed like an egg anyway
right you're much better off in a
moderate atmospheric period uh
area where you can actually fly let's
just say for instance uh
we're somehow adapted to the pressure
right if you have an atmosphere that
thick do you still need the same
aerodynamic
uh lift and everything to fly
or would you be just resting on the
actual
like the actual
atmosphere itself no no to your point
chuck
it is possible for the atmosphere to be
so thick right you don't have to fly
because you're just floating in it
that's what you're doing yeah that's my
point it's like it would be like being
in the middle of the ocean
the water is yeah i don't have to fly in
the ocean i just float in the ocean well
there's a difference between
density and pressure in that kind of
environment right so if
something can have high pressure but
relatively low density
although there is a relationship as we
all know the the so-called ideal gas law
right pv equals nrt
so there is a direct relationship
between well it's a relationship i don't
say direct necessarily because that's
mathematically
specific but all these different factors
come into account it
is possible for something like a a
balloon
to float in venus or on venus
in its atmosphere right in that case if
you were floating
on the atmosphere you would rather be
above the cloud tops of venus than above
the cloud tops
of titan because then you would have
more buoyancy
because of the the pressure the
atmospheric pressure that you get no but
but how about just my own strength
to fly just by you know put on some
wing looking right appendages right like
like all those old 1918 films where they
show guys trying to jump off of
all those all those guys right if they
want a different planet with a thicker
atmosphere
i bet some of them would have flown away
they
probably would have some of them might
have been successful but again the only
problem is that everything else has to
be adapted accordingly
right if your wings get crushed and
shredded because of the pressure
before you even get down there that's
going to be a very icarus like situation
i'm just picturing a guy falling from a
cliff flapping his
arms going if only i had been on venus
you really think those are his last
words
[Laughter]
it's probably oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
all right we're going to take a quick
break when we come back more star talk
sports edition cosmic queries kind of a
grab bag but it's about it's about
it's about athletics in space and but
when we come back let's talk about sort
of more exotic
things here on earth on star talk
we're back star talk cosmic queries
sports edition
and we're just talking about sports in
space and on earth and all the ways that
the laws of physics
dictate what you can and cannot
accomplish
and i've got with me chuck chuck nice
man and gary o'reilly i know and i got
my
resident geek in chief charles liu who's
got his
own sort of fan base within the star
talk
fan base they're people who are all
into chuck chuck charles luke charles
sorry if i say chuck i really probably
mean
chuck nice but occasionally a chuck
slips out when i'm talking to you
charles so
just i know i just i mean my twitter
handle is at chuck liu
that's right oh it is okay all right
yeah yeah yep so
so let's keep going we've got uh these
are patreon members
sort of exclusive questions that they
get to ask so
who's up next this is violetta your
number one fan
she's an astrophysics fan and she's a
sports fan she's
she's asking about the two main types of
muscles fast twitch slow twitch
fast twitch are good for quick bursts of
energy like sprinting and slow twitch
are good for endurance but supposedly
people genetically have one or the other
so which one would be better for space
travel
also and this is the kicker ps i'm the
fast twitch type
i can sprint from home to first base
like you wouldn't believe
whoa i love it absolutely fantastic most
baseball players are
primarily fast twitch types because you
you have to be
ready to move at any given time and then
move explosively when the opportunity
happens so if i remember
correctly violetta is indeed an
excellent baseball player so
i'm not at all surprised about that and
i think charles there's a there's you do
get a combination
but then the majority is one or the
other yes and
every muscle yeah every muscle has a
mixture and in fact
uh the slow and fast twitch uh the fast
twitch muscles so-called themselves are
actually divided into two kinds as well
the type one we call the slow oxidative
and then the type 2 there's a 2a
fiber which is a fast oxidative and
glycolytic
fiber and then there's a 2x which is
just fast glycolytic fiber
so um what does all that mean like
all right so does that mean i can run do
you tell me the fast twitch fibers have
slow twitch fibers in them
uh no each muscle has a number of fibers
in it
and a combination of fast and slow the
mixture of those two
that's right is is where you wind up
with your particular brand of fast
twitchiness and slow twitch
and from people who have an equal amount
they just sit around
and do nothing
okay so the perfect mixture is good for
the thumb on the remote control right
you what the actually the so folks like
to do triathlons
right um they our course are are slow
twitch supposedly because everything is
an endurance sport
but i could imagine a sport in space
someday where you combine slow and fast
you have to do both kinds of things like
run the equivalent of some sort of
marathon
and then quickly sprint a hundred yards
or something and then shoot a gun
and then throw a distance yeah
we have those sort of sports right now
and if you think about
basketball if you think about soccer
they're explosive
but they're over extended length of time
and you don't get breaks so
we kind of have a combination of that
sort of thing so yeah it's uh yeah so
lucky for firelitter
charles we always any anytime anyone has
portrayed people in space
everything is kind of in slow motion
yeah you need that strauss walls to
carry you through that
there is no fast twitching going on in
space
so what's up with that or is that just
our our
how we imagined it the the again because
we don't have to push against gravity
we don't have to sustain any muscular
activity
right you produce a burst of impulse and
then everything
flows out of that right so you feel like
you're not doing anything so the answer
to violeta's question specifically is
and and violetta one of these days
please tell us how
whether we should pronounce it violetta
or violeta because you know it matters
um and we want to get it right the
answer to your question violetta is
that because everything matters as far
as
fast twitch uh and the impulse and then
what you do with that impulse after you
stop the impulse fast twitch people are
definitely better
at space sports than slow twitch people
that would be my guess
and just to be clear just to highlight
what charles just
said right and and gary here's just
something interesting to know
in soccer you can explosively go from
like zero to sort of high speed
in space you just have to do that once
at the beginning and you just
float the rest of the way at that same
speed whereas you're always overcoming
the fact that you're slowing down
because you're
there's friction between you and the
road and you need to change the
direction and all the other things
the change direction is another sort of
point of acceleration charles
tell us about acceleration going from
zero to some speed that you didn't have
before
and acceleration changing direction just
put that on the on a table here for us
well when you are speeding up right
acceleration or slowing down
deceleration physicists normally just
call
deceleration negative acceleration so
you're just moving back and forth
depending on that
now when you are going from no speed
to a new speed right uh that
is actually a quick burst of energy and
what you're doing is you're changing
your net momentum
so you're exerting a certain amount of
acceleration
over a certain amount of time and and
force times time
right is what we call impulse it's a
version of momentum and so
when you're trying to accelerate from
zero to something it's how
fast you can exert the force and for
you know how long a period of time that
determines
how fast you get to when you get to the
zero to the whatever
and i'm fast
i turn out the lights and i'm in the bed
before the room get dark
you float like a butterfly and sting
like a bee too
rumble young man rumble
wait but charles i wanted you to talk
about what it means
for acceleration to also refer to a
change in your direction
oh that's true when you're going around
in a circle for example
you could be going at the same speed but
because you're changing direction every
moment you are
changing you are experiencing an
acceleration
we physicists as you know neil think of
acceleration as a change both in
how fast you're going and what direction
you're going and so as a result you have
to take both of these things into
account
if you're out in space you kick off
you're in one direction
and unless you can push yourself or kick
off in some other direction
you're going to stay in the same
direction moving forward a straight line
right until you are acted upon by some
force something else
and that's where you have to lose the
mass that we were talking about yeah
yeah or
or get help from something bigger that
has mass
like right isn't that well yeah
gravitational gravitational
exactly right you'd have to come really
close to a planet or something
and come at just the right velocity and
you know you have to move the speed and
direction such that you don't get
captured by the object but then you can
borrow so like planetary billiards
speaking of a new sport gravity assist
that's what i'm talking about see what
size what size would you
how small could you make objects like
that and and then
have that sport would it have to be
planets whoa
well you you kind of need really large
amounts of
mass right so you might need like white
dwarf star or neutron star material
damn that that's and that would allow
you to produce enough gravitational
effect
within say the space of a typical
football pitch or something that's crazy
um well how about this then back to
magnets
how about you have like a game like
billiards where
the idea is to uh transfer energy
by colliding the balls so that they
actually end up
hitting a magnetic pole and that's how
you sink it into the pocket
instead of a pocket it's the pole and
you have to would that work
or would it be something like if you hit
it on the wrong angle
like it would just go off forever you'd
be like
look at that i lost another
electromagnetic force follows the
inverse square law
just like gravity does so
it is mathematically appropriate if you
use magnetism
or some sort of electrostatic repulsion
or something like that
to mimic the behavior of what gravity
would do to us here on earth
that would be perfectly acceptable the
challenge is
that here on earth because we're all on
the surface of
the planet right we all experience the
same gravitational acceleration
to very very uh nearly identical amounts
so whether i'm at the end zone or
whether i'm at midfield i'm still
experiencing 9.8 meters per second
squared acceleration
if you're using electromagnetic stuff as
soon as you move
some distance you're going to wind up
feeling a difference in the amount of
force because your
source is so concentrated compared with
the earth which is so broad compared to
our football
or our sports arenas shall we say cool
interesting all right well give me some
more questions
all right this one is from roman procup
and roman says hey gary do you think
it's possible to improve the shooting
speed by engineering materials on
football shoes similar to how we have
improved shooting strength with hockey
sticks are you sad
you didn't experience these impacts of
science
in your active career in other words
bro are you are you sad you're old
you're
you're an old partner yeah yeah it's
like brother you're like too old to have
technology
in your sports so absolutely had leather
helmets you know
i don't think we can get a kick point in
a boot
like you have in a hockey stick an ice
hockey stick
and but although that just increases the
speed and the power
immensely what i could imagine is
something that we've discussed from time
to time
and why major league baseball doesn't
have aluminum bats
and i said it for you because the exit
velocity is
so so fast but if you put something
that's lightweight and strong maybe like
aluminium
or a ceramic plate in in the in a
kicking position on the foot
maybe you could improve the exit
velocity off but wait charles
charles would you you break your instep
break
you'll break someone's shins if you miss
the ball
yeah charles let me ask you if yeah is
is gary right here do you want
your shoe to be more rigid or do you
want it to have some kind of a springy
textured skin so that
there's like a double sort of
springiness to when your foot makes
contact with the ball
which of those would be better it
depends on whether you want force
or control yes right speed or control
this is true for any material
if you have a longer contact time you
can impart
to it more force right because the
maximum amount of force that you can
produce per
given unit of time uh you multiply that
by more time
you wind up with more net force or
impulses
right but the problem is the longer the
contact happens
the more the ball and your foot
have to interact with one another thus
creating sort of
micro forces or directional changes that
are beyond your control things that are
not
mathematically so the instant your foot
touches the ball
is not the instant the ball leaves your
foot that's right so you'd have to
recalibrate what that all of that would
mean
yeah what it would mean in in soccer
specifically
is that you wouldn't want to pass
off of that because if you passed off of
that
part of your shoe then you don't know as
well where the ball is going to go
but if you were shooting with that part
of the shoe that would be to your favor
because it'd be like kicking the ball on
the valve and the
keeper would not have any idea where the
ball would go because there's something
good enough yeah but when you're
listening to your friends you
end up just screwing up
so they did some years ago adidas
brought out
a range of boots cleats called
the predator and it had these rubberized
areas on on certain parts of the boot
that would allow for more contact as you
just described charles
and therefore allowed for accuracy now
you can't change your footwear that
sounds like cheating to me
wow there you go no that sounds like it
there's less there's less slippage
between yeah just ripping the ball right
so if you get grip on the ball
i can now rotate that ball better so
imagine
imagine table tennis bats with stippling
nice on one side that yeah we call them
paddles here this is america jack
okay the word bat is for bass
freaking ball okay someone got out of
the wrong side of bed didn't they
little america jack set you back on the
next boat
oh i don't even get a plane i get a
no boat no no the olympics are starting
soon neil you can't do that
i can't do that all right i just have to
get my merc
chops going all right let's get another
question we've got a couple minutes left
in this segment before we get to like
the philosophy of it all in our third
segment so right let's
let's find another question who's next
here all right eric varga
you've mentioned this previously in a
tweet a few years ago where you said
a winning overtime field goal was likely
enabled by a third of an inch deflection
to the right caused by the earth's
rotation
the coriolis thank you very much so
paying attention in class
i was wondering and this is interesting
is there an ideal directional
orientation for football stadiums and
could that
be given could that could take full
advantage of this effect from earth's
rotation
so when i when i did that calculation i
didn't trust my answer
and i sent charles liu an email and i
said
charles i want to post this did i do
this right all right this is
this is the double checking that happens
always in science if you get a result
that like no one had thought about
before or is it a little weird
maybe you didn't do it right did you
carry the two and so charles gave me the
charles lu seal of approval
i went with the number i made the
assumption
what wasn't an assumption was true for
that stadium that the stadium was
oriented
precisely north south and so my sense
was that you get maximal coriolis
deflection uh if you did that but then
charles you told me
that it doesn't have to be north-south
it could
i don't see how you get a coriolis
circulation if it's east-west
it depends on how far
directly east west if you're exactly
east-west
then you're not going to get a
deflection from that particular the the
east-west rotation of the earth
right yeah it's all a matter of where
you are the problem is when you kick a
ball
right you're not always kicking it
directly exactly even
there is wind involved oh yeah of course
no no all
other things being equal all i said was
that the rotation of the earth
influenced the path of the ball
all other things being evil and it only
matters because the ball
hit the freaking upright and you have a
round ball hitting a
cylindrical pole fractions of an inch as
any baseball player knows
can make a big difference in the in the
in the
in the resulting reflected direction
that's right
so no you're completely correct that
going
due north south perpendicular the closer
to perpendicular
you are to the rotation of your frame
the more of the coriolis effect
there you go the object will experience
so the answer to this is exactly north
south put all state if you if
put all stadiums exactly north south
exactly north south
right and then try
not to ever kick to the right side of
the center
because then the coriolis force takes
you out of the game rather than into the
game
all right so it doesn't matter which
direction on the field you're kicking
no each direction it deflects to the
right right thank you
interestingly right yeah so
uh you want to put all your sorry in the
northern hemisphere too yeah
yeah in the northern hemisphere it'll
always deflect to the right
and the equator there's no you got
nothing
and then when you're in the southern
hemisphere everything deflects
i'm going to go out on a limb here and
say any gm picking a kicker based on
this
[Laughter]
and i may not be too good at it
we've got a lot of saber metric type
things going on in sports these days
right
i can tell you this if your ball bounced
off the upright and went
left and not score versus in and do
score
and that and and a big game was on the
line there you're going to be wishing
you had
the laws of physics in your favor from
the choreographers
true and isn't sabermetrics all about
the tiniest little things that can
influence the probabilities of what's
happening
that's right and the statistics of them
trying to
squeeze knowledge about the sport
activity
from the numbers and the data just from
the date
yeah a whole other thing we got to take
a quick break when we come back
we'll try to think philosophically about
all of the science that's going on in
sports
and there's a question that i think i
saw there about spitting on your hand
when they want to throw the
the baseball and wouldn't that give you
less grip rather than more grip i want
to make sure i'll
lead off with that when we come back on
star talk sports edition grab bag the
physics of sports
on earth and in space
we're back star talk sports edition
cosmic grab bag but it's really
physics of sports on earth and in space
i got charles luke charles you're
tweeting at chuck
nice i'm sorry yes
i'm having a problem with twitter at
chuck
lieu yes h u c k l i
l-i-u okay so i hope i didn't uh no
disappoint people who asked
chuck nice questions no nice can answer
my questions just as well as i can is no
problem
now that was the funniest thing you've
ever said
so uh chuck liu liu and
uh chuck nice comic we got you on
twitter there yeah
yeah and my three left feet yes
does it have the my in there my three
left feet yes
okay so i assume you're right footed so
this means you're you're clumsy
it's like a dig on your own coordination
is that right
totally okay
you're not you're not saying that
secretly you're another species right of
humans
no i i i've never been that clever
okay we got questions that are more
philosophical this segment but i want to
go back
uh someone had asked a question about uh
spitballs i think so who who who carried
that which
uh let me jump in here uh richard l
sanders
uh why does a baseball player spitting
on his hands
improve his grip oh his hands we're not
not just a pitcher
instead of lessening his friction
thank you big fan of the show well
you're welcome richard hope this is the
answer you're looking for
yeah charles this is a mystery to me
it's always been a minute plus why would
you want to hock a louie on your palm
right there there is a difference here
we're conflating two things i believe
one is the spitball
right which is where you're spitting
your picture you're spitting on the ball
you're trying to get it as wet as
possible
yeah so when you throw it then it winds
up with weird aerodynamics and the
person who hitting it has a hard time
hitting it that's a so it winds up with
aerodynamics that not even the pitcher
can predict so
nobody knows what it's doing yeah it's
like a knuckleball on steroids
right okay that's the first thing so
that's now outlawed the last person
thought to have ever thrown a spitball
in legal competition
with satchel paige because he was
grandfathered in and allowed to pitch it
until he retired
but and nobody wanted to hit that ball
because no they did not no no no no no
[Laughter]
the idea of spitting on your hands is
very similar to
where and chuck jack
and there they are invoking the
grandfather clause on black people once
again
but this time it helped him out okay
fine satchel paige from the negro
leagues then who
made it into the majors one of the great
pitchers of all time
yeah um now the the reason people spit
in their
hands to grip a ball is a completely
different thing
that's more akin to someone getting a
paper towel damp
before wiping a table of crumbs
the idea of a little bit of moisture
increasing the ability to connect has to
do with static electricity
right the the reason dust clickings to a
wall for example is static electricity
and and if it's dry and has enough
static there
then you can't get the friction
necessary to grab the ball
it's a surface effect so you're not
trying to coat the ball
and coat your hands with fluid so that
they're slippery
but instead you're adding that little
extra bit of moisture that gets the dry
stuff off
of the ball and your hand so that you
can grip it better and thus be able to
throw it
effectively okay now how about was it
was it poppy who's the one
who spit into his hands when he had
hitting gloves on
that it's like dude these are like
soft leather gloves now you're spitting
on that on top of that what what what
are you doing i
i do not know that one i said big
puppies big poppy yeah white puppy well
if you you're talking about in all
fairness he just hated those gloves
[Laughter]
my my guess there is that maybe
there was a mental process where if you
i don't know have you ever like know the
difference between
wet leather and dry leather they they
slide differently
yeah they do actually you know now that
you say that maybe
better exactly it's really true if
you're trying to open a can of something
and you have like a a dish towel it's
way more effective if it's slightly damp
than if it's completely dry
that's right so i think they'd be that's
that's what uh what's going on there
okay all right so even on leather a
little bit of moisture can make a
difference in the grip
here's the problem with big poppy
spitting into the gloves he hits a home
run
and then wants to high-five me around
the bases dude
no you gotta have your you gotta have
your wet wipe ready right
you get an elbow big boy
all right so uh let's come on up with
some of these philosophical questions
what do we have there
who's next uh right uh sam
couch will there ever be a point when
humans
reach a fastest possible time in other
words
will there ever be a point in sports
where no more world records could be set
because humans have reached the lowest
possible
and wait to turn over page time assuming
you can finish a race in zero seconds
when that happens how will timed sports
progress
so what will we keep diminishing time
for the hundred meters the 1500 meters
until it's done in zero seconds is that
is that the question
until usain bolt just finishes this race
the day before he started it yeah he's
there before he left
um i i just think it's that point where
are we capable
of diminishing our world records
substantially
anymore well let me i'll lead off with
this but i want to hear charles's
response
you know you remember the banneker mile
right this is
when when was this 80 years ago or so
roger sorry
the bannister the banister yeah where
there's
no one will ever run a four minute mile
or a beat a four minute mile
and they're talking about the physiology
and everyone because no one was doing it
and so the urge to think you've hit some
limit i think is very strong
within us yet that has never seemed to
be the case
in reality so charles what's your
reflection
on the limits of world records i do
believe
that it's possible we are reaching
some sort of asymptotic limit right
where
at there is some point beyond which we
simply cannot
exceed however i don't know what that
limit is
we humans i think the roger bannister
example is excellent
there are other uh limits that
supposedly humans could never get to
by the way when if i remember correctly
when he finished the mile in under four
minutes
didn't he bring two other people with
him under four minutes
uh i don't know if that happened in that
one race but within
uh a year many other people had broken
the four minute one yeah
cause cause because the mystique was
gone that's right
same thing with the two-hour marathon
now haven't we is it kip koji
surprising enough kenyan runner um
if i'm not mistaken um they seem to own
the marathon these days
uh yeah to break two hours for a
marathon
i mean that that was basically the holy
grail but that seems
it's not official yet because it's not
being done in a race or with sanctioned
shoes but
it seems like it's doable as it were
right so we could get to a limit someday
but i am not going to make a prediction
as to
what that limit is in any sport and gary
has made sure that a lot of our
programs our sports edition shows have
focused on
improving human athletic performance but
not just
who's going to work out harder but it's
what kind of technologies are brought to
bear what kind of nutrition
what kind of maintenance of your
physioskeletal system
that you are maintaining so i it could
be that we have to start going
in these other directions it's not just
it's not just psychological and it's not
just
who's working harder and i think if we
ever do reach a limit
like it's at just a tap out point
then what we'll do is turn to uh
augmentation yes so that we can break it
and then they'll accept that
that everything as long as it's within
the rules we change the rules
charles here's what i thought about this
when i saw swimming records getting
broken with such frequency
and i said to myself this can't keep
happening at this rate
and then i realize how you do this okay
this is how you do it
so swimming used to be time to a tenth
of a second
all right now it's to a hundredth of a
second so
maybe future world records you need to
track a thousandth of a second
and then world records beyond that a ten
thousandth of a second and we all be
celebrating oh you beat him by three ten
thousandth of a second
whereas that was not even measurable
decades ago by the
by the stopwatches that were used and so
you can still set world records but
you'll do it
asymptotically it's you're approaching
whatever that limit is we don't know
what it is but
each next increment is littler than the
previous one what do you think of that
charles
that make happen someday it just hasn't
yet
uh well we are measuring swimming and
hundreds of seconds
yes but the records are still being
broken by approximately the same
increments
oh was that right i didn't check yeah
okay we could break them
asymptotically if we're actually
reaching the asymptote but we're not
there yet we just
okay i got it going to your point chuck
if we had ligament replacement
the man who's been injured more than all
of us is always talking about wanting to
be the bionic man no no it's not but you
see
you're not going in there to repair
damaged ligaments you're going in there
to get stronger
ligaments therefore you're able to put
more muscle in there you're able to
generate more power if that is what you
need to do and therefore you may be able
to enhance your performance and this
i don't know if that is within the
regulations or whether that would seem
like a body doping
yeah i said full body prosthetic what's
that arm still doing here
gary just carried when robocop won he
totally he
was he went all robocop
that was a line and robocop lose the arm
we thought we could keep we could
no lose the arm that was right full lose
the arm
yeah that's the bad guy said that
exactly
super cool all right give me some work
we blew a lot of time on that one but it
was an important
point of philosophy there all right we
have there here's one for gary hunter
q-tone says yo yo keep it hot this one
is for gary the man
in international football how come the
united states fails to produce
high-level male soccer players our women
consistently prove themselves and
compete to the best
how come we are having trouble creating
a usa world cup team of
men that can achieve what the women have
already achieved nba
has international programs does this
have anything to do with producing great
players
gary why do american men suck at this
okay and
let's just get paid more than the women
okay
that's a conversation for another time
otherwise we will be on this podcast for
the next six weeks
um the u.s men's national team are
producing
this country is producing a lot of
talent and it's not just
average you've got players now in
not just the big leagues in europe but
the biggest clubs
you have western mckinney who's playing
in one of italy's top club juventus
oh you're saying americans are going
abroad our top americans are competing
abroad that's what you're saying
yeah because they so why can't we gather
why can't we staple them all back
together here and then have a national
team
you do you bring them together for the
national team events
but at the moment you've got players uh
you've got rainer
young guys so talented he's a dortmund
in germany
you've got christian pulisic who's in
chelsea and london
you have got all sorts of u.s players
out there and when they bring
them back they bring back an extra level
of knowledge
it it goes through the coaching staff
and this is a process it's maybe a bit
slower than hunter wants
but i can tell you now it is gaining
momentum it's gaining so so we have
singularly
really good players but we don't have
the depth yet to sustain that
as in with an inter league with league
play i mean you've got one player
georginio
dest who is playing in the first team at
barcelona alongside lionel messi
you're getting there it's just maybe not
as quick as some people want
all right there you go you stay out of
america
you'll make it happen eventually
eventually
guys we got to call it quits there
charles give me give me some final
reflection here
to send us out okay we've been talking a
lot about
performance enhancement right and also
in the previous segment
chuck was talking about feeling about
cheating
and i think it's important for us in
this overall philosophical idea to
realize that
we often use the term performance
enhancement
to euphemize cheating you can
enhance your performance all you want as
long as it's within the rules both the
spirit and the letter
but the moment you're actually going
outside the rules
then that's just cheating we shouldn't
call it performance enhancing so some
let's say somebody is caught for a
performance enhancing drug
just say they used an unallowed drug
they cheated
and that's the kind of philosophical
idea
the difference i think gary between the
performance enhancement
and chuck what you were talking about in
terms of cheating so i go to the gym on
performance enhancing i swap out my
achilles tendon
with with carbon nanotubes
and i'm cheating and you're cheating
right unless the rules allow it if the
rules allow it then fine go for it
but if you don't don't try to tell me oh
it's just performance enhancement
no tell me whether it's cheating you're
not cheating or not
that's my take chuck charles you're you
said it right
and i don't think i think that's
unassailable
wisdom insight and advice to us all well
hey uh thank you for having me it's
always such a pleasure to see you always
good we gotta get you more i miss you
we gotta get you more all right all
right guys we gotta call it quits there
chuck nice goodbye to you thanks then
gary o'reilly and as always uh charles
liu our resident
geeks bertis expert
uh i'm your host neil degrasse tyson
your personal
astrophysicist as always keep looking up